من دبي تنضم الينا المتحدثه الاقليميه
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه هاله غريت مرحبا
بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض بدايه
لماذا فشلت اتفاقيات وقف اطلاق النار في
السودان حتى الان
مرحبا وشكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه لا
يمكننا نقول انه فشلت يعني شفنا بعد
التقدم خلال وقفه خلال الاتفاق ولكن صحيح
انه كان هناك مخالفات كثيره
ونحن مع شركاؤنا السعوديين نراقب هذا عن
كثب يعني راينا انه الجيش السوداني قام
بهجمات الجويه راينا انه قوه الدعم السريع
دخلوا الى اماكن مدنيه يعني دخلوا الى
منازل الناس يعني صحيح انه هناك كان كثير
من
المخلفات والانتهاكات ولكن كان هناك كذلك
كذلك
ايامات او ساعات هدنه وهذا كان مهم جدا
لوصول المساعدات الانسانيه وبالنسبه
كيف تراقبون وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
اذا لم يكن هناك اصل المراقبون على الارض
عندنا اليات مختلفه يعني عندنا مراقبه
جويه وكذلك عندنا شركائنا وحلفاؤنا
شركائنا يعني منظمات غير حكوميه الى اخر
داخل داخل البلد ونحن نرى عن كثب ونحن
نعرف ماذا يحصل داخل البلد
والبيان المشترك اللي ارسلنا مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه امبارح يعني كلمنا
بتحديد ماذا يحصل داخل البلد وهذه كانت
رساله للجهتين انه نحن نراقب عن كسل ماذا
يحصل داخل البلد لا يمكنهم يعني داخل داخل
الفنادق يتكلمون على اتفاق وعلى احترام
والاتفاق ولكن بعد ذلك يقوموا بانتهاكات
نحن نراقبون هذا ونحن نرى ماذا يحدث داخل
البلد ولازم محاسبات لهذا كمان لازم
تمديد هذا الاتفاق لان لازم يعني مساعدات
الانسانيه يدخل الى السودان الان هذا اهم
شيء ساناتي على نقطه تمديد الهدنه لكن
تحدثي قبل قليل عن العواقب ونسال عن عواقب
انتهاك وقف اطلاق النار من قبل الطرفين ما
هي الادوات التي
ستستخدمونها في وقف هذا الانتهاك تتحدثون
منذ فتره عن ادوات اخرى
هذه الهدنه كيف تنظرون لهذه الاشتراطات هل
يمكن تربيه اي اشتراطات هل يمكن ان يكون
هناك يعني دعينا نقول
مقابل لهذه الهدنه من الطرفين
[موسيقى]
يعني بالنسبه للولايات المتحده الحل لازم
يكون السوداني السوداني وقابل هذا الصراع
مبدا كان هناك مفاوضات بين كل الجهات
المعنيه القوات العسكريه والقوات وكذلك
الجهات المدنيه وكان هناك تقدم قبل هذا
الصراع يعني السفير الامريكي كان يشتغل
ليل نهار الان كذلك يشتغل لنهار هو ما زال
في السعوديه
وبقوم بتنسيق مع كل حلفائنا والشركاؤنا
لنساعد يعني حل سوداني سوداني لهذه الازمه
ولكن يعني لازم خافض التصعيد العنف
والقتال ليس الحل هذا فقط يؤدي الى يعني
معانا الشعب السوداني وليس الى اي حل خالص
لازم تمدير هذه الهدنه ووقفه اطلاق النار
لمساعدات الشعب السوداني الان اذا لم تثبت
هذه الهدنه لم يتم الاتفاق على وقف اطلاق
النار هل سيتم اللجوء بالفعل للعقوبات
مباشره
يعني لا يمكنني ادخل في في فرضيات كما قلت
يعني يوم يوم الى يوم نرى ماذا يحصل داخل
داخل البلد الان وفي مباحثات يعني يوميا
كل ساعه مع كل الجهات المعنيه نحن كذلك مع
التنسيق مع الاتحاد الافريقي يعني هم
عندهم يعني فكره كذلك اللي حل هذه الازمه
ونرى كل الادوات قدامنا
لنساعد الوضع داخل هذه المحادثات برعايه
سعوديه وعلى ارض ايضا كذلك سعوديه وطبعا
بالتنسيق مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مع الخارجيه الامريكيه ايضا اريد السؤال
عن الدور السعودي اليوم في هذه الازمه
السودانيه في تقريب وجهات النظر في ارساء
الهدن او وقف اطلاق النار ايضا كذلك كيف
تنظرون اليه
مهم جدا يعني المملكه العربيه السعوديه
شريك وحليفه في هذا الملف ويعني نشكر كل
جهود الذي تبذل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالنسبه للملف السوداني الان كما قلت
النوالسفير الامريكي هو مازال في جده
يعني في اللجنه التنسيق ومراقبه وقفه
اطلاق النار ونحن نشتغل مع حلفائنا
السعوديين يد في يد لنشوف حل الى هذه
الازمه داخل السودان
شكر من دبي انضمت الين المتحدثه الاقليميه
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا جزيلا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات